everybody sipping on wrong but
tons
[Music]
it makes you want to pull and you know a
little body roll and pull too over here
calling all my lovelies Bruno Mars has
plenty of music as you can see to set
the mood for love but now he has a drink
for it too Brian Clem is here to show us
how you can have a romantic you see what
I did there that's good man that's good
Valentine's Day first and foremost
introduce us to Silver Ray rum so well
first of all you know 24 Karat magic
thank you for inviting us back again we
love you guys so thank you of course but
silver rate is uh essentially just cut
and dry it's a single estate Cuban style
rum made in Panama okay and we have four
marks but today we are featuring our
chocolate rum because Valentine's Day is
right around the corner yes and we
wanted to show you what it can do you
know what I mean let me show me what the
chocolate can do okay we got a magic mic
too you know what I mean all right so
the reason why we're using the Negroni
today to Showcase is it's just it's it's
a very very easy drink to make okay
um not only is it very easy to make the
ingredients are very accessible you can
go to a you know a BevMo a Total Wine
um most I mean not most I mean honestly
pretty much all bartenders know how to
make this job okay okay so it's a
cocktail that a lot of people know
absolutely absolutely you can impress
your date with this yes it's typically
made with gin but we're throwing in a
little bit of chocolate okay I got you
thank you so much what I also love is
that all the ingredients are natural
exactly exactly yeah yeah and so this is
usually equal parts one one one okay but
what I'm going to do is I'm gonna do a
little one and a half
um on the chocolate being that it is
Valentine's Day and hey it's chocolate
it's a little extra yeah you know what I
mean you know what I mean there we go uh
now we're gonna add a little bit of ice
okay and then we're gonna give it a stir
that's the hardest part right there
that's it that's it so super simple
super easy boom just like that you can
build in the glass you can bacon just
stir it boom just like this I mean I got
my hand in my pocket okay you know what
I mean I love it now if you make this
for your date that's even better don't
don't make it you know behind closed
doors let her watch you make sure let
him watch you make it yes yes before
before dinner after dinner
um or when you get back home and you
just wanted something to sip on this is
a perfect cocktail okay now
you don't mind absolutely what Bruno
Mars
do you think represents this drink
that's a good question
um
Versace on the floor oh and that's a
good one for Valentine's Day too
wow okay that's delicious thank you so
much absolutely thank you for having us
back again we appreciate it yeah of
course yeah anytime thank you JC I'll
send it over to you all right